House Majority Leader Kevin McCarthy
apparently is the only person left on
Capitol Hill
congressman okay well what here we are
congressman I mean you should be you
know stuffing stockings at home and you
know hanging the mistletoe and and and
all the fun stuff you do in California
but here we are the government will shut
down in two hours did you all wait too
long I don't know that we've waited too
long if we look at the house because the
house has passed funding before we as
you know we've had the five billion in
there the challenge really lies and this
is what the viewers have to understand
the house did pass a bill that protects
and secures the border the Senate it
takes 60 votes so when it really comes
to the question of shutting down it
comes to Schumer does Schumer make a
decision to shut down or not and this is
a fundamentally different shutdown than
any of those in the past because we have
already funded three-quarters of the
government so when it comes to defense
our military men and others and women
they're all taken care of in this
process but this is too important to let
keep going we know what's happening
along this border we know we needed to
have be secure and think about what
Schumer's just said a couple weeks ago
he was for providing money for the
border but he's afraid it would affect
Nancy Pelosi vote for speaker January
third I gotta tell you though back in
October you and I talked about this at
the time when Paul Ryan said we're gonna
do this big fight about the border in
December we have a conversation that's
gonna happen we all knew that was
ridiculous okay I mean you were not in
that camp but for two years Paul Ryan
and I everyone hears me says I like him
very much as a person he has not been on
the president's side on this wall he
never wanted a wall he never believed in
the wall he didn't like it he didn't
like a lot of what Trump was saying
about the wall so here we are at the
eleventh hour and this is all on Trump's
shoulders I find it outrageous that's on
the president shoulders he's someone who
actually wants this done and I got to
tell you mazie Hirono I know you and you
and she are good friends
mazie Hirono congressman from the
senator excuse me from Hawaii on
television
blaming Fox News
basically talk radio let's watch he's
got some right-wing loud people yelling
at him on Fox News and suddenly he says
well I don't think I'm gonna sign it so
it is very true that he will bring on
the shutdown and he has to take
responsibility for it any effort on his
part to blame the Democrats will be such
well she said the BS were there Congress
yeah is this a Fox News talk radio
right-wing pundit shut down or did the
president kind of say it's do or die
here gotta do it you know the president
campaigned on this the president said he
was going to fight for this all along
and this really comes down that it takes
60 votes in the Senate but the president
is doing what he promised just like he's
done across the country on everything
else from getting tax reform on others
this president is a fighter and I know
you might disagree with me but Paul has
been fighting for this wall as well
maybe didn't think at the right time but
here we are we're in this fight and
what's changed this week remember when
Nancy Pelosi was sitting in the Oval
Office she looked at the president said
well you don't have the votes in the
house well we overwhelmingly proved
that's not true and we had sent the bill
now to the Senate so it really lies with
the Senate and the challenge there as
you watch the vote before it comes down
to what Schumer Schumer has some power
and that's unfortunate for the president
but more importantly it's unfortunate
for America we see what's happening
across this border we need a secure
border it happens yeah that's what
that's why I'm still at work right now
yeah well again I beg to differ I think
Paul Ryan could have gotten that the
votes for that Goodlatte bill you only
you came within like what 13 votes are
passing that and everyone was told it
wasn't gonna happen I think it could
have happened and it would have happened
but look you're right I mean the Senate
has has the cards now we really
appreciate your spending time with us
tonight and thank you so much